[Music]
i'm really sending all the songs
because they waiting for me i got you
because i like the other one but it's
just my verse
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
bleacher reports
pregame picks we got a live one from
brooklyn tonight
nets vs hornets this is the only show in
the world where we give you
the people at home a chance to win free
cash prizes by simply predicting
all the random [ __ ] that occurs in the
nba pregame
we're gonna be giving away a lot of
money tonight i'm doing jumping jacks
that i owe from last week
stay tuned so you can win some money but
let's get to these picks
baby hey how many is that so
i'm getting tired
how crazy is that wait is that a three
let's see that's a three that's a three
step curry wow my name i told y'all
welcome to pregame picks
let's get it and see y'all hey
we back but before we get into it y'all
hey lost man my damn fiber is hurting
for them jumping jacks man you know what
that you know what that is
you know what i feel like that's what
you get for betting against it that's
what you get for betting against me
that's what you get for betting against
me
hey but no real talk what's popping
brody i'm happy to be back with you on
this camera here how you feeling
i feel good bro what's up man what's the
word big bird
i got that from brian i just heard say
that the other day bro
yeah yeah i heard that too but hey you
know what we do
we here to get a people money you know
what i'm saying that's what we do we
give these people money so shout out to
everybody that's watching at home
but before we even dive to all of that
and how they gonna win money i gotta ask
you this
we were starting off the show with can
anyone stop the nets
from winning it all i want everybody in
the comments to let us know what y'all
think as well okay
can anybody stop the nes from winning it
off
this is this is this is real life p this
is real life p
and ironically god must know you saying
something crazy
cause my whole screen went black and i
can't see
can't see anything so
so yes they can be stopped you got the
jazz you got the lakers you got
everybody
but is it okay i obviously they can't
okay
let me rephrase it for you will they be
stopped
we talking about james harden who
playing like mvp right now
we talking about this team i think they
won 19 or they last 22
without kd the big three only played
seven games together
they just added aldridge they got blake
shout out to audrey he's making his
debut tonight
starting for them uh they got a guy
ain't nobody even talking about joe
harris is the chico
to be honest with you i'm not really
worried about the monster
yeah i'm most concerned with your hair
is more than the people that they're
getting from the buyout market if i'm
being honest
yeah um i ain't nobody nobody's scared
of all dressed though
ain't nobody's scared at all that's so
funny though i just go average or cool
eight nine
listen i feel what you're saying that
ain't nobody ain't nobody scared of
aldrich
but what i will say is i'm a little
scared of aldrich when he's next to them
dumb players that he's next with now if
i'm against if i'm going against
aldridge with the spurs
yeah i'm not scared but if i'm going
against aldridge and he got kd
carrie and hardin next to him i may be a
little scared
understandable but at the same time i'm
still letting you know you only know
everything's like
hit average like eight like nine maybe
10 if you ever double figures it's not
gonna be more than like 10.4
like it's just saying going it's only
one basketball
there's only one basketball that's all
hey and this is that's the same thing
for blake
yeah that's the same thing for blake
kyrie has to go for his 30s
kyrie got to go for 28 every day curry
has to do that hart don't really got to
do that he do that when you feel like it
but yeah but harden's going to get get
you his 25 he's 25
11 and 10. you know you know you know
how he do
when kd come back katie was averaging 29
and so
i mean dan i mean damn that's 29 28 20
i'm i'm going through the comments right
now lois
and it looked like we got a comment that
that i'm i'm rocking with
you probably gonna be rocking with two
because he kind of echoing what you're
saying
shout out to my boy king reggie mamba
and i like this comment so much
we're gonna give uh king reggie mama two
hundred dollars for this comment
he said what type of question is can
anyone
stop the nets he said man cut it out
lakers are defending champs and will
repeat easily
now that last that last word easily i
don't want to put that out there king
yeah that told me that
we might be taking 50 back lois another
thing i want to ask you bro
is how you feel about everybody whining
with the nets getting all of these
buy-off market players i
it's like it's mostly the lake affairs
it's mostly the same [ __ ]
yeah and they stand the same way so i
don't understand it
i'm the one who should be arguing right
now
we got somebody from the g league
let me know in the comments below you
know why you can't talk [ __ ] though
cause y'all done this before that's the
only reason look that's the okay i'm
like all right you know what
i'm like you know what man it is what it
is
what it is
i'm just making sure cause i re i
remember the warriors
i remember the warriors stacking their
deck signing boogie
it didn't work out how they thought it
was but they they signed him
on some [ __ ] i knew that yeah i knew
that though i knew that yeah i knew that
though
no matter no matter how nice boogie is
or was it just it's the system man you
got to play the system man we need a bow
get type player
we need a i just it's just like that you
know
i knew it was gonna do that but
but the world was looking at the world
the world is reading names
shout out to gravy7384 so
with that being said with the world
reading names
if super teams good for the nba or not
it depends y'all let me know how they
feel it depends on how they jail and
it depends on the players it depends on
the players like kd can go
anywhere average 30 the eat
easily so you know we should speak on it
no no no answer my question ain't no it
depends
our super team's good yay or nay
do you like when three stars team up
and kick everybody ass or or do you like
when it's paid i don't really care
i don't really i don't really care
because everybody's beatable i live in
the real world bro it's not social
that's not social media
i really live in the real world
everybody's beatable so [ __ ]
that shit's cool that's just cool and
whatever so i'm guessing we're saying
they're automatically going to win this
year
so since they got that they're
automatically going to win with repeats
what so you're saying they automatically
going to win this year because they got
your killers y'all yeah y'all tell me
y'all tell me in the comments i'm gonna
keep it a buck all right i'm gonna keep
it a buck i see what lo
saying i respect my brother's basketball
man that's why we do this show every
week i wouldn't be
everybody is beatable and what he's
saying and that's a that is a fact
everybody is beatable
but we know that some juggernauts unfuck
wittable
like the golden state warriors when they
came off the 73 wins and they added kd
were they beatable yes technically yes
but we were there
[ __ ] but we were all [ __ ] with when
we had it without you
we won the championship we won the
championship
and then we were 73 and nine
like bro these are back to back like
nobody in the laws nobody but
that but okay that's cool okay [ __ ] but
you know [ __ ]
happens sometimes some days somebody's
jumping
jumpers jumpers really might not be
falling defense
might not be there
shout out to my boy they just came off i
don't want to use this
i i don't want to use this word because
they grown as professional man but he
said that it makes
the game unfair super teams make the
game unfair and i'm talking it's cool
it's cool but how many how many
superstars do you know play defense
not many so they're just adding a lot
yes
hell yeah you're adding a lot of offense
but you you're taking away hella defense
so
so people should be scoring as much as
as much as as much as like they score
because the whole
they're not they're not playing they're
not playing damn defense be real come on
brother
[ __ ] is averaging 50.
when you're a super team defense won't
matter because if
just like the nets i think i think the
nets are beatable because they have a
big portion
a big hole that they're that they're
missing and that they're lacking
but i wouldn't be saying that wait wait
hold on wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait what's that what is that
what is that where the hell well
first of all it's that interior they
don't have to play joel
joel joel and beat nobody on that team
is going to do [ __ ] with joel embiid
who they got to brooklyn deandre
but deandre is a young ass man deandre
don't start for a reason
deandre
i i i just want to let you know deandre
are grown as a man too though
i i don't know if you really joel embiid
is a joel embiid is a fully grown ass
man he a full-grown ass
aldridge that they just signed yes hey
sit your ass down cause you don't want
no smoke with nb uh who else they got
over there
nick nick claxton i like nick claxton he
don't want no issues with jordan beat
but too small blake i love blake no
smoke with them
so that's the whole will that whole will
that hole be enough
but you just named one player
yeah you come on man hey look you got
you got my boy right here asleep he
knocked the hell out cause he listened
to the [ __ ] you talking about
talking you just named one player you
just named one player
if i look at the milwaukee books they
can do the same thing if they smart
enough
you take brook lopez out and you put pj
tucker in and you move greek freak to
the five and he gonna feast on that he's
still going
one i don't think the bucks he's
sleeping on the ball good enough
but but but you put him in that interior
you change that offense around
instead of having big ass brook lopez
out there and i don't think none of them
said this can mess with him either
same thing with the lakers bucks the
lakers can go hey man lopez shoot too
many damn threes
low they too many threes
he may he make some but he just shoot
too many there
their team won't win hey because they
just say
they don't have the right pieces
no the the no daddy i don't want to get
all the bugs bro
i already want to get on a bucket yeah
they're not going to first challenge
yeah the sixes the six is good
but but but the six is so good bro for
500
no for 500
will kyrie irving make
12 and a half or less
in his first 20 attempts over under let
us know in the comments for a chance to
take home 500
we are not doing things how we used to
whatever your answer is it's your answer
if you're right you can be selected as
one of the five to take home five
hundred dollars
uh either way did you pick lost kyrie
first twenty shots were they making
thirteen who they
who they playing the hornets but lamela
but lamelo is out the hornets
hey it's just warm-up stuff man it's
just warm
you said it like lavello today uh kyrie
stopper
hey hey no but um
yeah just in warm-ups i don't i don't
want you to think i'm saying lamella or
kyrie stop it at all
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah he gonna make 13 because
the first the first four five six gonna
be layups
okay so everybody at home lost is
telling you he gonna make them because
the first four or five are gonna be
layups
um
kyrie is a guy carries a guy that uh
he he'll take he'll take about three
minutes of just dribbling
i want to say i'm gonna say uh you know
what i'm gonna take that back kyrie
gonna make uh
he gonna make 13 his first 20. for sure
i want to send people i was gonna just
go against the grain but i want to i
want people to get this money there's
500
we're talking about this
why are we talking about 13 13 for 20.
huh it's lamelo because i've been seeing
i've been seeing [ __ ] all over all over
twitter
especially since my boy anthony edward
has been doing a little hooping as a
late
but is lamelo ball the rookie of the
year
or nah i don't know he was he was
because he was leading there he was
leading that category won't he
i believe so yeah he's still
getting it to me it's obvious huh
okay he's he's still a rook idiot yeah i
don't give a damn about his injury
i mean yeah it's obvious and he's just
not playing right now in the back
you know to keep going but if you're
leading every
every category what
that girl that boy that go that boy i
need a camera
expeditiously on kyrie we tracking the
first 20 shots
we need him to make more than 12 so
y'all can be taking home
500 unless you made the mistake of going
against us
and you potentially a slight chance of
being correct could still take on 500.
production is wrong i'm getting the word
hey i got word in my earlobes that
production was wrong he ain't not yet
why kyrie don't ever come out with the
damn team
hey yo i told you why i told you why
he's a superstar
hey man if i was a superstar he's not
really around
he's not really on the team he's not
really on the team he is
like he is the t you know you ain't
lying because i remember in the
i remember in the summer when they hire
steve nash
hey kyrie was it that go my boy forget
what i'm saying that go my boy i don't
even
i ain't got to say what i was going to
say that boy out there on the float
let's get a camera i want a 24 7 camera
on kyrie please i'm actually
respectfully you know what i'm saying
can we just please get that 24 7 camera
on kyrie i don't
see nobody else
hard enough harder not playing easy
harden is out hardening blake griffin
out
so we got calories is that a make yes
sir
yes sir we got one make down already for
one p
p you gotta keep me updated p you gotta
keep me updated p
oh for gas you can't see okay the first
basket then we're going to
show y'all i'm a versatility hey but i
can hey
i can't hey but i can hear it though i
can feel it cause i i know i just know i
know i know the boy paul
uh hey he come right here he come right
here whoop how off the backboard he
missed it lois he
messing around bro i know
cause i know i know i know i know it was
his elbow
that boy don't keep his elbow tough
that wasn't even something i didn't even
know he just threw that up
the first one was a reverse layup that
she would have liked
and that second one he gave us some [ __ ]
think before it
yeah i know you like that being pink if
you know if y'all
he two out of three so far come on kyrie
mid mid-range i already know that let's
give these people some money
i already know
let's go all right now we got carrie
with the rock
they told me to work on my play-by-play
low so i'm gonna show you like oh pink
pink
kyrie behind his back between the legs
oh [ __ ] hey we gotta hey we have to fix
lois's monitor milo's gotta be watching
this so we can get y'all
the big bad [ __ ] live ping i'm not boys
i ain't never seen kyrie warm up like
this before kyrie wanted to have to get
his own little
he doing this he doing this [ __ ] he and
his bag what he doing what what is he
doing i need
what is he doing in and out behind the
back
between the leg behind the back
oh my god oh my god oh my god
heyp why you gassing it why are you
gasping
your [ __ ] yo [ __ ] back yo [ __ ] back
no oh [ __ ]
damn he did just make another mirror hey
you gassing it
you gassing it i'm over here right there
hey i'm telling you when you when we
done with this
some somebody make sure they send loads
some clips of what kyrie was doing i
know lowe's don't seen a lot of bing
bing from kyrie
so he ain't missing i already know what
he did but you said
you said he would act like he ain't
never acting
hey no yeah he was acting a fool like
that he must know we watching
he must know be watching he acting a
damn fool he knows no he must know
he he he no damn well i can't see he'll
never show me something
he's probably doing some moves he don't
stole from me
and he just shook up with uh terry
rozier that's another mate by the way he
made his first four out of five so it
looked like we are on our way to sending
five people home
with five hundred dollars five out of
six now
um and they want hey they had a prompt
for me los
i was gonna surprise you and do a um a
side bet that we you know we
we normally do outside bets and i was
gonna ask if kyrie was gonna say what up
to any of his old teammates and he just
said what up to rozier so damn
damn it to myself for not bringing it up
earlier yeah what's your name
what you think yeah what you thought
what you think kyrie that type of person
you know he gonna speak damn
hey no because against the lakers him
and lebron
they never said what up did they did
they ever say what's up i think we was
waiting and it never happened
no just the camera didn't let us go they
were talking the whole game
hey hey hey
hey lost he hitting corner three as well
left side of the floor now
he'd i made 10 out of 12. we three more
mix away from sending five people home
with 500
that's another make that's 11. come on
come on kyrie two more come on
i told you i told you all that i could
see
he just took a chance hey i already know
p
p i already know p i already know hey
lois take a
take hey take us home lois he hit the
free throws now one last shot
oh that's too easy that's too easy back
your break struggle
to my fella's crib hey bat the brink
struck up to my people's crib that
brings
we so cold we so cold with this [ __ ] my
boy lois ain't need
he can't he ain't even seeing the [ __ ]
he just told y'all the result of it
pull up the winners for me please pull
up don't win this one
i already told you told y'all come on
man
come on man i i want to know why in the
hell more people ain't tuning in to this
show you're winning free money
me and lois gonna set you up for free
who passes and you slam dunk it
and like lo said you just back up to
your crib
and shout out to all my winners that
debris this is what you do
because i've been getting dms and
messages this all you have to do when
you win
and we announced that you won at some
point throughout the day or throughout
the night
you want to check those dms and you're
going to get your money
a lot of people be panicking like ppp i
won i won what i do now
simple you just sit back wait you wait
for that dm on the bleacher report app
and you're going to get that cash move
name shout out to my boy wayne and
birdman
cash money records with dreams come true
get it
hey that was very professional pete i
like that man
i got a switch on my back you know what
i'm saying i'm flipping out hey here we
we got winners lost we got winners i
want to shout out some of these winners
we got
daniel o'rourke shout out to him he's
500.
richard we got cedric white cedric
cedric parents who look crazy they
spelled cedric with s
his cedric is spent with ass but he
found alex richards my cousin my cousin
oh so shout out to the centers with the
ass and we got blue arrow burgers
i don't know what the hell that is and
we got rayfield allen
no relation to ray allen or what
hey rayfield you just won 500 do me a
favor and let me know in the comments if
you related to rey
bald head peanut here allen let me know
you know bald hair peanut butter you
don't you ain't a real ap
p you are right man how how is it
everybody tuning in to this show
and people making 500 in 15 minutes
that's that's what i'm saying bro
if i if if we wasn't on the show i would
for real be
in this show on the comments trying to
get my 500 dollars every week
that's f i would be in the comments
i would be in the comments are you
serious
and then and then listen to this you
know what's crazy lois
you know what's crazy well i'm trying my
hardest not to be in the comments right
now
we we we not done that was just our
first one now we got a whole nother one
for two hundred dollars
and this one is would annette's last
shot be a make or a miss
lose i ain't gonna lie we be battling i
ain't gonna lie i'll be competitive i'll
be trying to get my [ __ ] right
and be a little bit more right than you
but when it comes down to these making
mistakes you'll be knowing so i'm gonna
let you guys this one
let the people at home you know what
they should be thinking of how they
should answer this
talk to me hey for the rest of the show
pete it gotta be
it gotta be known are we going when the
blood buzzer blow or when the light go
off well i mean when
when we going when the lights go off
as soon as the lights go off that's it
nah i say no changes
let me talk to my people at production
production loss want to do
when the buzzer goes off and now with
the lights y'all let me know if that is
possible if not
then lois we just got to do the lights
ben gonna tell us in a minute
he said we can't lose we can't see it
okay
so it would be impossible as for us to
know so lights
okay lights all right so
ap last question so as soon as when the
lights go
you know when they just go a little a
little light so is it dark dark or a
little light
yeah it's dark it's dark it's gonna
change last week it changed colors and
went green
so i'm guessing nate i don't know the
arena but it's probably gonna go dark
maybe a red or blue light for the nets i
don't know
but we're gonna it's gonna be uh we
gonna know it's gonna be a hard
you know we just go okay so look we're
gonna go
we're gonna go with um we're gonna go
with uh
uh a a mist we'll go with a miss cause
they're not gonna be done
shooting listen to me they're not gonna
be done shooting but the lights are
gonna be off
so that's what it is i was thinking
that i was thinking i was thinking miss
only because
only because we're not doing the full
finish how we used to do because every
time yeah in the past
they would end with a dunk but because
we're not following
the every shot but it's just the lights
i'm gonna miss because usually somebody
throw up some [ __ ] ass shot
from half court before the lights go off
and hopefully yeah
we can watch people in the money so all
the other homeless watching right now
let me let us know y'all y'all
predictions
on what me and lowe's got if y'all just
if y'all disagree with me and lose
that's fine
that's me just don't cry to me when you
don't win no money put it in the
comments yeah hey
and my camera people production real
quick can we find somebody in the
stadium doing some [ __ ] they're not
supposed to be doing who's asleep
who who's shoving that hot dog down they
throw it a little too quick if you know
what i'm talking about
show me something i feel like laughing i
feel like laughs hey don't you
hey look hey don't you hey man listen
i'm about to get off this show
i'm gonna do some play-by-play while we
waiting on them lows because i forgot
that you can't see
right now we got a lot of mid-range and
three-point shooting
we got joe hey well well the image the
image you
just put in my mind bro don't give me
that well start off start over
i know i know you've been i can't see
eating a hot dog a little too fast
but i know you've been you've seen
somebody eating a hot dog too fast
well you should be seeing nick nicholas
claxton the center for the nest he's
taking threes right now that just show
you where the game is at right now
who else is out there that look like uh
they just [ __ ] landry [ __ ]
yeah they [ __ ] all right we got that
hey that's a north carolina boy
hey that's a north carolina boy too hey
hey
they big banking they said they been
banking with the food bro
be a being for production is crazy
no they've been if they don't i'm gonna
try to just play my play-doh
with them either give me a some nachos
maybe some nachos or pizza man no hot
dogs
go back listen i'm gonna paint this
picture for you lois
to all respect with this family but
first of all my brody
got a damn knicks jacket on at the
barclays i don't know if he don't if he
know he's at the next game
but i like his lawyers long game he he
got
um last shot hey
uh i didn't even peep 25 seconds left
let's get the cameras on the shot
lows i'mma hype it up and get you to
play by play for you since my since you
can't watch
i want to add to my scene how we just
made one second just made one uh
they starting to line up we got less
guys shooting somebody is about half
court dribbling the ball out that looked
like kyrie
he might be throwing this [ __ ] up in the
last second we got five
four three two one the last shot is
a
one second lost lights ain't go out
the last shot was a miss host the last
show
yes let's go let's go let's go
i couldn't even see today and we still
won my people's
hell of money i couldn't even see today
we still want my people's hell of money
so we gave 200 away to the mamba guy for
the comment
we sent 500 people home with 500 a piece
and now we just sent five more people
home with 200 every round we send people
home with money
we got to see some people in the stands
stuff in their face
with all type of chicken fries and
gatorade and [ __ ] hot dogs being ate too
fast with the big bank we got kyrie with
the bing beans
but he still was a good sport he still
entertained us
so low we got to give it hey tonight i
want to give a shout out to lose
for being professional his [ __ ] went out
technology happens but he's still
maintained
lows get your uh post games i couldn't
see tonight at all
and we won everybody money
i'm literally hey i'm lit right now yeah
you lit
you lit let's pull up these winners
let's before we send it home let's see
the five people that's gonna be taking
home 200
um hopefully we got some some some more
some more people taking home more money
i don't seen some people double trouble
you know what i'm saying that's uh that
that's what i'm saying
i i would want a double double double
double
what double juggle
double juggle bro then i'm getting off
that's when you you i'm getting off this
camera i can't do this they showing a
replay right now i don't know who that
was that hit that backboard miss
but they bought it as hell uh we got
benji get buckets
we got our court back 25
we got uh friendly friendly jail i hope
i'm saying these names but we got
kaepernick with an
x okay and then we got eligio
vargas so all that i'm taking home 200 i
appreciate y'all for tuning in
we appreciate y'all for tuning in yeah
um i can't i don't i can't tell her that
it is my [ __ ] a little static
oh that's uh that's the backup point
guard what's the backup point guard name
with a c
uh lows for the next the little short
guy
kappa zola or some [ __ ] cupparizza
i don't know capar i don't know all
right i forget his name
what position it ain't cabaret cabaret
is a small four i think
maybe you is right man i hope that won
tlc but whoever that was
uh shaman is a two guard with the nets
okay
yeah okay yes two guard hey
as always me and lois
ben what was it production what was it
yes chioza chioza that's his name chioza
chioza was the backboard miss he was on
some paul drewes [ __ ] right there
that was that was one of them
i shot one last night like that
i ain't i ain't gonna lie i like your
honesty but i ain't never shot no [ __ ]
like that
but we want to say everybody
thank y'all for taking uh take taking
the time out to tune in with us
shout out to all our winners who took
home money lost one time for the one
time take us out with your big beat let
us see your big bank real quick
double cross burgers
i'm about to go on instagram right now
and still in and out burger
we out though hey i'm gonna post
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you